después de 36 días de paro de
actividades la región boliviana de Santa
Cruz ha suspendido la medida de protesta
luego de que la cámara de diputados
aprobara esta madrugada la ley del censo
de población y vivienda que establece
que se repartirán recursos económicos a
las regiones con base en la nueva
realidad demográfica del país a partir
de septiembre de 2024 la norma además
señala que se producirá un nuevo reparto
de escaños parlamentarios antes de las
elecciones del 2025 esta ley además ha
develado una nueva correlación de
fuerzas en el parlamento porque la
bancada oficialista del movimiento al
socialismo ha terminado fracturada la
parte de la bancada que apoya al
presidente Luis Arce ha aprobado esta
Norma con el respaldo de la oposición
mientras que la fracción de la bancada
que todavía responde al ex presidente
Evo Morales se ha opuesto a la
aprobación de esta Norma es más Evo
Morales y sus legisladores han acusado
al gobierno de Luis Arce de una alianza
con el derechista y opositor gobernador
de Santa Cruz Luis Fernando Camacho
quien ha sido uno de los líderes de esta
protesta la Ley Sin embargo no está
completamente aprobada debe pasar
todavía al senado donde el ex presidente
Morales todavía tiene poder por lo tanto
habrá que esperar para ver si es que
termina promulgándose lo que sí ha
sucedido durante esta jornada es que los
cívicos de Santa Cruz han suspendido la
medida de presión y por lo tanto la
gente ha procedido a levantar los
bloqueos que se habían montado en las
rotondas y en las esquinas de Santa Cruz
hay que recordar que Santa Cruz es la
capital de económica de Bolivia y que
este paro había provocado grandes
pérdidas al país y por supuesto a Santa
Cruz